je veux une chanson pour évoquer sa
différence de taille car la forêt est un
artiste élan courteau au profil atypique
puisqu'il mesure deux mètres 06 tout de
suite j'ai vite compris que le basket
malgré la taille
ben en fait j'ai fait du basket petit
quand j'étais grand à 12 ans et est en
fait j'étais pas très bon port ça me
passionnait pas spécialement quand j'ai
vu ça et je m'amuse beaucoup sur les
planches après avoir pris des cours de
théâtre car la forêt investi le petit
écran dans la série vdm et le grand
écran avec le film brise 3 en 2016
aux côtés de jean dujardin une joue le
rôle de carl le jeu à la casse va t elle
s appelle la classe
[Musique]
on m'interpelle tout le temps ait ebola
aux gens combien machin m du médecin a
pas marre et je suis bon et non en fait
ça permet de vous d'ouvrir la
conversation avec les gens c'est quand
même super également musicien
autodidacte il choisit de parler de son
quotidien dans son premier titre le
géant qui mêle humour et musique rock
le clip a été tourné en partie à
elancourt a été finalisé pendant le
confinement
[Musique]
j'ai tourné avec un petit téléphone un
stabilisateur nappes et quelques copains
qui m'ont dépanner pour tenir les stater
tant de temps à autre mais voilà donc je
me suis baladé un peu dans les yvelines
un peu partout à pied au téléphone en
attendant de retrouver la scène quand la
situation sanitaire le permettra karl la
forêt donne rendez vous à ses fans tous
les jeudis à 18 heures sur les réseaux
sociaux pour une web série au titre
évocateur le manteau personnalisés mais
sacrément assaisonner et je vais donner
tout ce fric qui est plus de service
public
alors les impôts bon pur
[Musique]